all right we're very happy to have my
next guest live for the remainder of the
show we have a lot to run through with
him his new book book is titled let me
finish and it's in bookstores everywhere
Governor Chris Christie thank you so
much for being here Congrats on the new
book you've been on every show except
like farm tools weekly that's all right
all right guys I got some questions yeah
my god I can't believe I'm not on farm
tools weekly how does that get that PR
person on it let's go move move all
right well I want to start with
something you said on Colbert last night
see if you don't come on my show first
I'm gonna have to be really really
amazing let's take a look do you regret
try maybe get elected I made a decision
at the time that I thought he was gonna
win the nomination after I dropped out
and that I preferred him to Hillary
Clinton and that's why I made the
decision it wasn't a whole lot more
complicated than that and I still agree
with what his policies are more than I
agree with Hillary Clinton's listen he
has turned the Republican Party into
something different than it was when I
started to run for president now would
you consider that something different
good or bad
ultimately for the GOP governor in some
ways good and in some ways bad from my
perspective you know in the good ways
that he's turns and I think his
toughness on China has been something
that the party needed for quite some
time and I think his continued efforts
in that regard he's continued efforts in
trade in general I think are good and
he's gotten a much better deal with
Canada and Mexico than we had before and
I think he'll achieve the same things
with the EU and with Japan I think he's
been better for us in terms of our
regulatory policy and has put much more
of a focus than we were putting on when
we controlled Congress and could have
done more there too on regulatory issues
now in the places where I disagree I
think there are times in foreign policy
where he acts impulsively you know
whether it's some discussions about
Syria and and the cross currents that
event involved there I think he should
take a more deliberative approach I
think he is now too
a more deliberative approach but listen
in the main I would say he's made the
party better because he won he'd beat
Hillary Clinton okay yeah I mean do you
think you know I've been a big fan of
yours for a long time everybody's
listening to my interviews with you on
the radio you know know that but do you
think you could have beaten Hillary
Clinton in Ohio Pennsylvania Wisconsin
all those states yes all right yeah I'm
sure absolutely do because of your
positions on trade illumination the
things that motivated those voters to
turnout and which obviously he had the
money to he had the money raised but
yeah there's no question that I think
that Hillary Clinton was an
extraordinarily flawed candidate and she
needed someone who's going to be direct
and go at her and call her out on all
the things that she had done a Secretary
of State and the things she was
proposing and have a prosperous they
were the way we would lose to Hillary
Clinton is if we had a candidate who was
not direct who was not blunt who was
part of the old guard whether that was a
Jeb Bush or or or a Marco Rubio or a
Scott Walker
I don't know that those guys would have
been able to pull it off because they
would have been more PC I don't think
you need I mean I'm getting you caught
in a prosecutorial trap and you don't
even know it that's why I love having
you on was you're tired you've done a
lot I'm just look I asked you whether
the party went into a good or bad
direction and you said the old guard
wouldn't a baton Hillary and you're
absolutely right they would have gotten
restored they couldn't win their home
state governor they couldn't win Florida
they couldn't win you know their key
states Mitt Romney couldn't win Michigan
against you know when he was up against
Obama so they couldn't win so the new
guy comes in and says look I think all
your policies are have been wrong on
trade he thinks a foreign policy had
been too interventionist in Iraq and and
in other parts of the Middle East we've
upset the applecart there and I think
the people that really got their
attention because people are very war
weary whether it's Syria or they're very
war were weary well we got 2,000 troops
in Syria everyone wants to knock the
crap out of Isis and Trump's like well
okay well what why exactly are got our
guys still getting killed there and
I think ultimately you know he's
probably gonna be more cautious but the
the parties turn was in the right
direction under Trump and I think you
were closer to that and that's what I
said I said in in the main I think it
was important because the biggest thing
he did was win and and in those areas in
foreign policy where I've disagreed with
him at times and I maybe am a more
aggressive more interventionist policy
than he would have I don't think that
would have determined a loss in the
election to me when contrasted up
against Hillary Clinton
with all the other advantages but in the
end it doesn't matter he was the nominee
I was the first person to go out and
support him you were telling me I should
do that and I went out and I did it and
I think you know in that represented a
big moment in the campaign when someone
who had been seen at least as part of
the mainstream because I was a governor
even though a very different kind of
Governor in a blue state you know I
think that was a big turning point in
the in the primary campaign which I
believed he was going to win and even
more important for the general election
well and we're gonna get into more of
what might be in your future down the
road but I want to play something from
today or yesterday maybe but this is
Chuck Schumer talked me about these
border negotiations that are ongoing
perhaps to avert another government
shutdown let's watch we've come to big
agreements before for example on budgets
and Russian sanctions what was the
common theme when the president stays
out of the negotiations we almost always
succeed when he mixes in it's a formula
for failure so it asked President Trump
let Congress deal with it on its own
what about Schumer your old nemesis hey
listen you know the reason he doesn't
want Donald Trump involved is because he
wants to try to roll over congressional
Republicans and and I just think the
idea you know there used to be I used to
have a saying in Trenton that there were
only three important numbers in Trenton
41 21 and 141 voted in the lower house
to pass a bill 21 in the upper house and
one which was the signature of the
governor it's the same thing with
different numbers in the Congress and if
you don't have the president involved
you're not going to come to a solution
and so the idea that he wants to keep
the president out I think is
very Machiavellian on his part he
doesn't want the toughest guy in the
room at the table and he wants to try to
roll some people and quite frankly I
think the president has to be involved
any negotiation without the president is
doomed for failure because he won't
agree when someone has their glasses
down on their nose they are a lot more
credible and believable I stop I stop
and listen now is chris christie i want
to start with your appearance on colbert
again last night and an interesting
comment you made on your book tour let's
watch would you have been a better
president than trump yes okay so a lot
of modesty a lot of tequila i like it
but what does what does trump need to do
to win in 2020 and are the democrats i
started the show by talking about the
lurch to the left of the democrat party
and Fanta side green energy all that are
the left actually helping Trump now as
we move into the election cycle they're
significantly helping him by continuing
to move to the left by putting people
like Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
out in front and being a spokeswoman for
the party talking about a seventy
percent tax rate talking a Kamala Harris
talking about eliminating all in health
insurance companies and having insurance
for all and let's not forget our friend
Howard Schultz am I now I'm gonna get a
t-shirt made up that says run Howard run
let's go Howard get in there run as an
independent all of those things are
processed things that are helping to
shape the the landscape to make the
contrast even better what you want in an
election politically is a great contrast
you have a great contrast between Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton that's what we
want again we don't want people to
muddle things up in the middle we want
contrast do you want a socialist society
or do you want a capitalistic society do
you want a society that respects life or
do you want a society that denigrates
life do you want a society that gives
opportunity for everybody or where
government controls everything
Donald Trump has to be able to draw that
picture very starkly clearly the
Democrats do what they're doing gonna
help him he needs to get better people
around him Laura you know so many of the
mistakes in the first two years of this
administration and I write about this in
the book have been unforced errors
unnecessary errors by people who don't
have the experience in Washington DC
it's great to be a disruptor I was a
disruptor in Trenton I would have
disrupted in Washington but I also need
to have people around me and he needs
that people around him me as a former
prosecutor him as a businessman that
understands the politics of the Capitol
and it helps to avoid some of those
unforced errors like government shutdown
I think that you you are making the case
for you to be the chief of staff now I
know everybody knows I pushed for you to
be chief of staff I talked about it talk
about on radio tweeted about it and I
know I'm not getting in a Kushner or the
dad or I mean that's just I think that's
all pointless to talk about and
everyone's tip that to death I think
it's boring for my viewers my viewers
want to know Chris Christie is
no-nonsense you've known Trump for all
these years you have a good managerial
sense you are no-nonsense and you and
you can take criticism because I've seen
you take criticism because they're
giving it to you and you actually listen
to people would you consider going into
the White House in a in as a chief of
staff or even managing the 20/20
reelection campaign for this president
and I always told the president that
whenever he calls I will answer the
phone and I will listen to what he has
to offer and I always have and I always
will for two reasons one because I love
my country and I can't imagine a country
governed by the Liberal Democrats that
are out there running and two he's my
friend and I'm loyal to my friends and
even though as you you've accounted you
don't feel like he was loyal to you no
he wasn't and and and in fact is that's
in the book and I've read it all yeah
humility though and you and your
you know you're a big personality but
you had to humble yourself
we all have gone through those moments
and when in the buck that's right in the
book talks about the ups and downs of my
life and when you get knocked down it's
about getting up and fighting for the
things that you believe in in your heart
whether it's your family whether it's a
cause that you believe in a
philanthropic cause or whether it's your
country and all those things are things
worth fighting for and it's never a
straight line up Laura and it hasn't
been for me but you know me right and
yeah not for you and you know for us
we're fighters and I'm gonna fight and
if the president asked me to fight for
him I will always listen to a request to
fight for my president and my country
did the book get in the way of you
becoming chief of staff I mean that
would have been kind of awkward as a
book working listen no because if I had
accepted chief of staff at that time the
book would not have come out okay I know
it's part of the deal all right governor
I want to talk about a report that
bubbled up in The Wall Street Journal I
know you saw that the White House
Counsel Pat's abalone was cutting some
secret deal with the Democrats that
would have ensured that they would have
gotten a liberal pick as a compromise on
the ninth circuit well we learned today
and I learned today that this was all
complete you know bull you know what
yeah and tonight it was confirmed that
the president announced his intention to
nominate these stars to the Ninth
Circuit Daniel Collins
Daniel breasts and Kenneth Lee two of
them scalia clerks all phenomenal
governor explain why is it so important
that the prep the president has really
done well on judges you didn't take that
off earlier why is it so important that
this Ninth Circuit is not allowed to
become a runaway in jumped and junk
injunction train that's going to run
over the president's policies well
that's what it is right now Laura it is
a runaway injunction train that
everybody runs to the Ninth Circuit and
the lower district courts in the Ninth
Circuit to challenge the president's
actions because they know that the ninth
circuit is the most activist ultra
liberal of all of our circuits and
that's why these these nominations are
so important
Donald Trump promised to transform the
federal courts and he has done great
work great work at the Supreme Court and
at the circuit courts but
he has not been able to get crack the
code in the ninth circuit he goes in
with Lindsey Graham pushes these
nominations through and fights it it's
gonna make a big difference for the last
two years all right governor Congrats on
the book we really appreciate your
spending some time good luck on farm
tools weekly they just texted they're
bugging you for them I'm rushing there
right now I want a retake